Because the graph involved estimating, we can't find the exact coordinates of
the point of intersection. So, here's another way that we can find it,
substitution. For this method, we solve for one of the variables, and then we
make a substitution for that variable into the other equation. Notice that for
these two equations, both of them are solved for y. I have y alone on one side
of the equation. Notice that both of these y's are the same variable. So, what
we can do is replace this y with what this y is equal to. We're going to take
10x plus 10 and move it or substitute it in for y. This is the process of
substitution. Now, we have one equation with one variable and we can solve for
this variable. We subtract 7x from both sides to get 3x plus 10 equals 12. Then
we subtract 10 from both sides to get 3x equals 2. And finally, we divide both
sides by three. So 1x is equal to 2 3rds. Remember, x is the variable that
represents how long we're renting the car. So, we rented it for 2 3rds of an
hour. Alright. Here's a throwback to fractions. What's 2 3rds of an hour in
minutes? Write your answer here. And don't worry about the unit. I've already
included it.